a big moment in in EU often dismissed as
out of touch with citizens needs em eps
past the abolition of roaming surcharges
by 2017 and rights on accessing the
internet across Europe you can use your
phone like you at home but those who
stay at home will not pick up an extra
bill there are exceptions excessive
roaming for example but another issue
for EM eps was people's equal access to
the net alongside big commercial or
government users net neutrality as it's
known an apparatus internet is the v60
infrastructure a technocrat a ferret
Zhukov who traffic thanks ear tratado
the form of big wall st. criminal sow
sales Teresa ont francia we apply amo
conciliatory interested I cheated in e
la de cosas tonk a diff arc racially
sistema pillow del Castillo headed the
negotiating team it is a kind of
abolishment of a sort of tax on free
movement of people in Europe it implies
eliminating aburria for so many
companies for so many startups in the
european space next stage smaller phone
bills after april 2016 even smaller ones
from june 2017 when the legislation
fully kicks in
you